similar concept but different
circumstances in green bay where aaron
rodgers will likely meet with the media
at some point this week as the packers
launched their off season program under
first year head coach matt lafleur and
the packers media sessions this week
have necessarily become more intriguing
because of last week's story from tyler
dunham bleacher report an exhausting
exhaustive and exhausting look at
what was going on in green bay over the
past several years with mike mccarthy
there as the head coach and chris so
many rabbit holes and so many issues and
so many things to dispute and rebut and
you know my understanding is the packers
privately dispute the idea that ceo mark
murphy said to aaron rodgers don't be
the problem i expect that rogers will
take that head on and say that never
happened but there's going to be a a
difficult one for rogers as well because
he's got that reputation for being
passive aggressive everyone will be
interpreting or at least trying to
interpret everything he says
he he needs to play this straight and
he's come out and and and you know try
to put 2018 behind him and focus on the
future and doing everything that needs
to be done to help his current team to
help his new coach
and uh i think the more he says
the more that we will have as media
members to parse through his words and
try to find hidden meetings i think it
would be hoove him to say as little as
possible yeah no i think he's got to uh
again you're right hey the the things
that are out there about him sensitive
you know
uh passive aggressive listen you know i
love aaron rodgers i don't know him uh
i've met him for 30 seconds in my life
so i have no like personal vested
interest here other than i love the guy
and the way he plays football on the
field but i hear all these things
throughout the nfl so some of it must be
true yes i get it now listen
i think it's overblown we're talking
about greg jennings who basically
exposed to us that it was personal and
uh there was issues there between him
and jer michael finley they didn't like
aaron rodgers you have a hard time
finding other players down the line
though that don't i mean a lot of the
players that have been there for a long
time have loved aaron rodgers and i
understand he's not perfect but i think
he needs to show respect to mike
mccarthy uh within this process yes kind
of end the rumor of the fact that oh
yeah mark murphy had to call me and tell
me don't be the problem he'll he'll
handle that head-on and and
debunk that whole thing but i guess
where i get a little frustrated again
too is you know people going with aaron
rodgers changing the plays and doing
things like that and not taking orders
well there's just more to the story that
we found out too you know again you know
changes plays yeah okay the coach wasn't
there in meetings at times i think he
has an issue with that you know okay
you've allowed the player to change the
plays when he does it then you can't be
mad at him because you don't seem to be
mad at him when he tells or changes the
play in the huddle and the nfc
championship or nfc divisional game a
few years ago it's against the cowboys
where he draws up a play in the sand and
throws a 40-yard laser to save the game
to jared cook who's falling out of
bounds to then go ahead and win the
football game so you got to take the
good with the bad again it was the
culture in green bay that has led to
this they went from a brett favre
gunslinger karius brett favre type of
team and they transitioned right into
that to br to aaron rodgers to where it
was oh aaron carry us save us do magical
things and therefore we've created this
guy who seems like he's almost bigger
than the franchise and we want to blame
aaron rodgers a little bit and i
understand some blame deserves to go
there but i also want to say part of the
culture was to make him into this and he
had no other choice but to be this guy
that could carry the team as well so
that's where i fight back i guess a
little
do you ultimately believe
what tyler dunn reported last week i
know there's a lot there yeah and i ge
it's it's it's it's one of these things
where there's so much in there yeah it's
hard to pick and choose and say i
believe some of it but not others there
used to be a story that i would tell uh
when you're trying to convince a jury
that your case is the right side and you
should vote in their favor if there's
some glaring flaw in the other side's
case it's like a chunk of rancid meat in
a bowl of beef stew you don't just take
out the rancid meat you dump out all the
stew i mean from your perspective did
you think
overall
that that tyler dunn's report about the
packers was persuasive yeah broadly i
thought that that was pretty yeah pretty
spot on spot on to the things i've heard
over the years in a lot of ways you know
i'm not gonna say i agreed with every
specific thing that i heard in the story
and all that but yeah i think broadly i
mean when we just talk about there was a
disconnect between rod you know rogers
and mccarthy i certainly do agree with
that some of the issues we've talked
about leading up to prior to this
article being released about mccarthy
not being a part of some of the game
planning and then calling plays we had
always heard those type of things you
know rogers having a chip on his
shoulder about mccarthy not drafting him
uh in the 2000 what was that five draft
six draft uh all that being personal
yeah i believe all that i've always kind
of heard those things and i think tyler
dunn just laid them out perfectly for
all of us to see and there's another one
mike i mean people are mad for aaron
rodgers having a chip on his shoulder
see this is where i don't get it's okay
for some people to have a chip on their
shoulder and then others not and that's
where i get crazed by the media
sometimes and the you know hypocrisy of
it we're gonna celebrate one guy for
having a chip uh but the other guy man
that chip's too big slow down you're
going too far here and i don't always
like that aspect of it either
well but it's one thing to have a chip
on your shoulder that's directed
externally it's another thing to hold a
grudge internally that applies to your
head coach and that undermines the way
that you regard your coach and maybe
you're more likely to view your coach as
an idiot like rogers reportedly did a
low football iq that kind of stuff you
you never get to the point where you
bond the way you should if that that
disrespect it predated the coach's
arrival and maybe the message in
hindsight is they never should have
hired mike mccarthy in the first place i
mean they had aaron rodgers around for a
year they presumably had an idea of how
he ticks maybe they should have realized
that this wasn't the best combination
maybe they should have hired sean payton
instead of mike mccarthy to be the head
coach he was the other finalist but i i
i think that it's more problematic if
that chip on the shoulder is directed to
somebody that you're supposed to be
working with and coming together and
trying to win football games with yeah
no i i won't i won't dispute what you
said there you're exactly right if it's
becoming personal to a guy that's the
head coach in charge and you're butting
heads with them because you're letting a
personal chip that happened years and
years before that uh kind of get in the
way of you know a fruitful business
career going forward as far as success
on the field between two guys i'm with
you there mike i won't dispute that
you mentioned a few minutes ago that you
only met aaron rodgers once for 30
seconds did you shake his hand when you
met him i did of course yes
if if you were not a spleenless
germophobe would you have ever washed
that hand again yes i'm not that
obsessive that i feel like that i have
to do that but you know what like i am
like you know how like john dorsey or
andy reed shook my hand of the combat or
at the nfl owners meeting and they like
they mentioned how big my hands were
right uh i did the same thing with aaron
rodgers because i you know again i'm a
i'm a football aficionado i love to sit
there and watch how guys grip the
football and do those things aaron
rodgers has gigantic hands so when i did
shake his hand i was very aware going oh
man those are some long fingers okay now
i know why he can throw that ball the
way he can that was the thing i took
away from shaking his hand
you know the bigger the hand the more
surface area for germs too oh that's
right you know be careful you know what
they say about big hands
big gloves are
i didn't say anything what was your
impression when you shook my tiny little
uh little boy hand you don't have tiny
little boy heads you got a pretty good
sized hand for a guy that's what what
are you 5 11
i'll take five eleven okay maybe five
ten and a half but you have some no i'll
take five eleven uh we'll go with five
ten and a half now that you said you
don't take six foot oh no we're not
going to give that you got square
shoulders and some long arms so you have
some attributes of like a six one six
two uh guys so there's something i'll
take six one yeah i'll take six one
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports